[Music]
and anyway like we heard we heard about
you i think through that and then um
when i was preparing for this and she
was like i really like amanda she
doesn't like the word panties
and and my wife bex also hates the word
panties for some reason and so she's
like no you have to look it up so um
thanks to my wife in my um youtube
search i or in my my google history says
amanda montel panties
and uh
we won't like cliffhanger that we'll
actually explain why so you did a video
series oh my god years ago this is after
you wrote your first book which is
called wordsworth was way before it was
even before that
no this was like i was like 23 24 and
just trying to like find my voice you
know
like see what i wanted to say to the
world and yeah i made these like really
cringy youtube videos talking about
language and gender that's the subject
of my first book word [ __ ] um and i
didn't know why i was making them
necessarily i was just like you know why
you do anything on the internet when
you're 23 24 or whatever in your 30s 40s
80s whatever whatever no shame um i am a
little ashamed no i'm not i like i look
back at those videos i'm like oh that
green screen oh that haircut like oh
dear um but yeah they would be on things
like why i hate the word panties or you
know uh i would break down some current
event in uh in the context of language
and gender or um you know play some sort
of game or challenge with a special
guest um having to do language and
gender and um yeah i oh god i beg you
not to look them up um yeah just google
amanda montel panties you'll find it
yeah i have a series where i was talking
about all these gendered words that i
hated and i would sort of unpack why
phonologically phonetically
etymologically sociolinguistically these
words were um not sitting well with me
uh
yeah i don't know i think that one just
didn't sit well with you because
um well there's a sort of childish
implication there's something
infantilizing about that um
uh panties dollies you know when you put
i.e on something it becomes diminutive
um so that was at play again i made
these videos like five six years ago um
that's my excuse but no i actually look
back and i'm like you know what without
her without that like cringy girl on
youtube i would not be sitting here on
the minimalists podcast so she she she
had she was doing something right she
was trying
it's like kind of how i look at my
my like 20s i just look at it like i
really
look at that that man like he's really
like kind of disgusting and douchey yeah
but i also wouldn't be the person i am
today without without without that dude
yeah much of what you've done is in
contrast to that person right in some
way or like oh i learned i don't want to
be him anymore and therefore to not be
him i'm almost defining myself by
by being someone other than him to me
this is almost the best form of other
rising it's authorizing yourself
right yeah
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
percent advertisement free